SANDEEP MURUSUPALLI: Hi,
I'm Sandeep Murusupalli.
I'm a customer engineer
with the Google Cloud team.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir live
webinar from the Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
Today, I'll be talking about
accelerating your cloud
adoption using API management
as an abstraction layer.
You can ask us questions
anytime on the platform.
We have Googlers on standby.
We'll be answering questions
live on the Q&A panel.
Let's get started.
So today, for the
agenda, the primary focus
is looking at our API management
as an abstraction layer
and see how it helps your cloud
adoption and acceleration.
So we'll start with a few
cloud adoption patterns.
We'll look at how customers
are using API management
in their journey towards Cloud.
We'll start with that.
And then, we'll come to
the Apigee Edge overview.
We'll spend some time talking
about what the product is
about, give you a very high
level overview of what we do,
and how it plays into the
whole adoption strategy.
And then, we'll come
to actually look
at three different
architectures on how people
are using Apigee as an
abstraction layer to move
[INAUDIBLE] to Cloud.
And then, we'll do a quick demo
showing some of these aspects.
And as we go along, feel
free to ask questions.
We have Googlers on standby
who will be answering questions
on the Q&A panel.
But I think what
I'll do at the end
is take some of the common
questions, common themes,
and answer them here for the
benefit of the larger group.
So let's start with the
cloud adoption patterns.
So I want to talk about
two things really.
The first thing is the cloud
is a well-understood thing,
with huge economic
and business benefits,
agility benefits,
productivity benefits.
People want to move to Cloud.
Enterprises and customers
are willing to move to cloud.
But there is some hesitation.
As they move their workloads
from their existing
infrastructure to cloud or from
one cloud to another cloud.
The reason is because most of
the core systems that they have
are hardwired to the
UIs, are hardwired
to the client or the experiences
that they're building.
So the moment you
think of moving
one workload from an
existing infrastructure
and putting it in
the cloud platform,
you're worried about
what will break.
You don't know which
of the integrations
are going to break,
which of the clients
will complain that
they're having issues.
So one of the common themes
we're seeing with API platform
as the abstraction layer,
once you have API management
platform as a layer through
which all your clients are
coming into your workloads--
whether they are on-prem
or on the cloud--
you have flexibility
to move things around.
You can know who is impacted.
You can know what has to be
done to rectify those impacts.
And you have the flexibility
to move your workloads from,
let's say, an existing backend
to a cloud-based pattern.
That is one common
pattern we are seeing.
It's a very simple pattern.
Once you have API management
as an abstraction layer,
you can move things around.
That's one pattern we see.
The second pattern we are
seeing is IT modernization.
As enterprises adopt
app modernization or IT
modernization, what we're
seeing is containers
are becoming a huge driver.
The reason is really simple.
Enterprises are looking to build
what we call as hybrid clouds.
A hybrid cloud
really is a scenario
where you have your applications
running both on-prem
and on the cloud.
And you want to have
a seamless experience
across these applications
that are running on-prem
as well as on the cloud.
That's the whole premise
of where containers
are becoming super important.
So what's really happening
is, as a developer,
you write your app, package
that into your container.
And the container orchestration
engine or the engine below that
is taking care of all
the abstraction for you,
of the infrastructure
underneath.
It's taking care
of all the scaling.
of how the VMs are
managed, so on and so forth.
That allows you, as a developer,
to package your application
into a container and just
worry about that piece of code.
In a sense, at the enterprise
scale, what's happening is
you have a huge variety
of applications.
Think of it as polyglot.
There are some teams starting
applications in Java.
Some teams starting
applications in Node.
applications in Go.
So you have a diverse
variety of applications.
And as an app developer,
all that you care about
is packaging your
application into a container
and give it to
orchestration engine.
And the orchestration
engine is taking
care of the abstraction of
the infrastructure underneath.
It's taking care of the
workload distribution.
It's taking care
of auto scaling.
It's taking care of
[INAUDIBLE] so on and so forth.
In the same way,
what happens now
is once you have this diverse
variety of applications,
at the consumption
level, you do have
to make sure that
these applications talk
to each other.
And that's where the
API management really
comes into picture.
An app developer, again, you
are responsible for the contract
or what your app is doing.
You make sure that the
APIs that you adhered to,
that you have the
application remain the same.
And once they do,
you onboard them
to an API management platform.
And the API
management platform is
taking care of things
like security, things
like visibility,
routing, and making
these APIs application-specific,
allowing your business
to institute more partnerships.
So in a sense, the Kubernetes
container orchestration
at the orchestration level,
as well as the API management
at the API abstraction
level, they
are the key drivers are to how
our enterprise customers are
modernizing their
IT infrastructure
or getting platform
modernization.
There is a small
extension to this really.
To start with, Greenfield
is not always a possibility.
You always have
existing applications.
So you cannot start Greenfield
and start thinking that I'll do
containers from next month.
Neither is it practical
for enterprises to say,
I'll take all my
existing infrastructure
and modernize it at one go.
I'll take one year.
And starting next year, I'll my
infrastructure is modernized.
In those cases,
again, API management
becomes an abstraction
layer at the higher level.
So you do have API management
taking care of the APIs
that are coming from your ESBs.
They are coming from your
VM-based applications, as well
as the applications that
are containerized that are
in the cloud platforms.
So this is a practicality
that we're seeing
with our enterprise customers.
And once you have
that abstraction layer
as API management layer,
you do have the flexibility.
And you can decide which
of these applications
you do want to modernize and
which are the applications you
want to move to the cloud.
And for the clients, all of
this is kind of transparent.
They don't have to know the
internal details of how your IP
infrastructure is built up.
So the common theme
across these two patterns
really is, as long as you're
able to come to a state
where your workloads
are either consuming
other workloads as
APIs, or your workload
is being consumed
by others as APIs,
you have immense flexibility
to move things around.
And that's what we're seeing
with our enterprise customer.
With those as the baseline,
what we want to do now
is talk about
Apigee Edge platform
and give you a perspective of
what the platform does to allow
you to do what we just said.
And before I get
there, this slide
talks about how
all of this plays
in the context of
additional value chain.
When you talk about
workloads, these workloads
can sometimes be
consuming applications.
These workloads can sometimes
be systems of [INAUDIBLE]..
But as long as you're able
to keep your APIs consistent,
making sure that the clients
won't see a difference,
whether they're talking
with cloud-based backend
or an on-prem-based
backend, you're good.
Similarly, you need to
secure all your APIs.
You need to make
them discoverable.
them measurable.
So that's what Apigee is solving
for enterprise customers.
Before I get to
architecture patterns on how
we are doing that and the
common patterns we're seeing,
I wanted to talk a little bit
about what we do as a product,
and what are the
components involved,
and how they are allowing you
to do what we just talked about.
At a very high
level, Apigee Edge,
it's the name of the product,
an API management platform.
It's one single product.
You can conceptually think of
it as three different buckets
or three different categories.
At the core, we
have API services
that is acting as
runtime sitting in
between your backend,
the systems of record,
and systems of engagement.
And then you have
developer services
that is allowing your
developers to get up
to speed, get on board, access
the API, play with the APIs,
understand the documentation,
so on and so forth.
And finally, there's analytics
that gives you visibility
into how your APIs are doing.
So to double click a little bit
into what these components are,
the API services, like
I said, is the runtime.
It's sitting in
between your systems
of record, your backends.
This could be, like I said,
your Kubernetes-based backends,
your VM-based backends.
They could be on the cloud.
They could be on-prem.
But these are your
systems of record.
And the clients
could be mobile apps,
could be partner integrations,
could be internal apps.
They are talking to the backends
through this Apigee Edge
contact.
So think of Apigee
Edge as the proxy.
The request come
from the client.
They come to these API
services, the runtime.
There, we enforce common
policies, common functionality,
like, let's say, security
or API key validation.
And we do things like
traffic management,
making sure that no
single developer is
going beyond the quota that
they are allowed to access.
Those are the kinds of things
that you want to do commonly
across your backends.
And those are the policies,
or those are the functionality
that the runtime is enforcing
for you on the request pipeline
as the request comes
from the client.
And finally, the request
is sent to the backed.
And now, in our
context, these backends
could be on-prem-based backends.
They could be cloud-based
backends, but for the clients,
their transparent.
So Apigee can take
it off routing.
For example, even if you
have to move your workload.
Let's say you have
a SOAP-based backend
on some appliance or some VM.
And you want to move that to
a Kubernetes-based backend.
At the the runtime
level, Apigee can now
know that there is a
switch that happened
in the system of record.
And we can make that transition.
And the client need not
go and rewrite his code,
or they need not change
a bit of the code
that they have already written
to do what they're doing.
Similarly, on the
response part, we
do a lot of things like
response mediation.
It's a very common scenario for
us to take a SOAP XML backend
and translate that to
an REST JSON backend.
That way, the clients are
comfortable consuming it.
And the backends can keep
updating the way they are.
So the summary is API services
is taking care of your APIs
from operations standpoint.
You're making your APIs
operationally ready.
And once they're
operationally ready,
the second thing
that you want to do
as a developer is let other
developers access your APIs.
So that is where developer
services comes into picture.
This is generally a
white label developer
portal where your developers
will come to access the APIs.
So they're coming into
the developer portal.
They do two, three
things commonly.
One is they look
at documentation.
Nobody wants to
read documentation.
So developers
services takes care
of giving them a sandbox where
they can play with the APIs,
send a request, change
parameters, send a request,
look at what the
response would look like.
So they have complete
parity around what
the API does before they
integrate this into their code.
The second thing that
developer services does
is it allows them
to access the API.
They can sign up for a key.
They can sign up for a token.
They can tell you what they're
trying to do with the API.
And they can get access.
And they use that to actually
send requests, get responses.
In a sense, they entire
onboarding of your developers
can become self-service.
It can help you in
two different ways.
One, if you are the developer,
you can put the API out there
in the API management platform.
And you're not worried
about each team
that is trying to use the API.
If there are five different
teams that want to use the API,
they're not coming to
you five different times
to learn what the API does.
And two, from a
business standpoint,
once the APIs are out
there from multiple teams,
from multiple sources on
this developer portal,
you can go and make the
business partnerships.
You can onboard more channels.
You can give them
access to the APIs.
And they can come to the
portal and onboard themselves
to learn about the APIs.
So that's the second
component of what we do.
One, it's API services.
That the runtime.
Making your APIs
operationally ready.
Second is the
developer portal that
is making the consumption
of these APIs easier.
So the net result
of these two is
you have teams of people who are
building APIs, onboarding APIs.
And you have teams of developers
who are consuming the APIs.
And generally speaking,
these teams are not the same.
They're not sitting
in the same room.
in the same office.
And sometimes, the
consuming developers
are outside your enterprise.
They could be your partners.
So analytics
becomes your insight
into how your APIs are
being consumed if you are
a developer who owns that API.
And if you're a
business owner, you
can look at how your
channels are doing.
Which channels are driving you
more traffic, where they're
coming from, all
the standard things
that you want to
look at to measure
develop your API program.
So that's the reason
why we have analytics
as a first-class citizen in the
entire API management platform.
So those are the three
things at a very high level.
And there's a lot more depth.
We'll cover those
in other webinars,
so you can learn
them in the follow-up
webinars or the content
that we put online.
But these are the
three things that
constitute an API
management platform
that we are as Apigee Edge.
And in the context of a cloud
acceleration or migration,
these three become
super important.
Because now, in addition
to your existing backends,
you're now introducing
new concepts
of cloud-based backends, the
manage services that you're
using, the containers, the
Kubernetes-based backends.
All of these will have
to be made transparent
for the clients for consuming.
So that's the context
of how Apigee Edge is
used in cloud migration
acceleration projects.
So what I'll do now,
now that we looked
at the common themes of
what customers are doing
with respect to
the cloud adoption
and how they're using containers
in the context of that,
and then we looked at
Apigee Edge as a product,
I'll walk you through three
common architectural patterns
that we're seeing
as customers embrace
their journey towards Cloud.
You can almost think of
them as a progression
or three different
scenarios that
fit together in the
maturity of enterprise
adoption towards Cloud.
The first pattern that
you see here on the slide
is an area where an enterprise
customer is mostly on-prem.
They have VMs.
They have Kubernetes.
They have other services
that are on-premise.
The primary mode
of infrastructure
is essentially on-prem.
But they want to use
Cloud for a new project,
for a niche project.
It could be, as an example,
here is a customer who
has most of their software,
most of their IT on-prem,
but they're looking to run
a prediction using a tensor
flow on GCP.
Now, they want to use
GCP for that one project.
But the prediction that comes
out of that tensor flow model
will have to be made accessible
by other on-prem systems.
Because that is how your
websites are being served.
That's where your mobile
apps are being served.
So the final output
of that prediction
could be an API that
has to be consumed
by the on-prem systems.
That's the problem statement
in which Apigee acts here,
or that's the problem
that Apigee is solving
for enterprise customers.
There are two, three
things that we do commonly.
One, as you talk to
your new project in GCP,
you don't want your
on-prem systems
to learn new authentication
models or to, let's say,
do a service account-based
authentication that you
may normally have in
your cloud projects.
So what you may want to do is
integrate with your existing
identity provider, or IDP.
So in that case, Apigee
could be that layer
that is talking to
you IDP, making sure
that the calls that
you're making to the Cloud
platform or the
tensor flow model,
in this case, the prediction
API are being authenticated
against your IDP the same
way that your other systems,
other mobile apps,
other web apps
are consuming [INAUDIBLE]
APIs [INAUDIBLE]..
The second thing that customers
want to use Apigee for
is enforcement of policies.
Sometimes, especially
when you're
doing your first,
second projects
on the Cloud platform
on the cloud,
you don't want sensitive data to
go out of your on-prem systems.
So now, in this case,
we're talking about,
let's say, a prediction API.
And the request of
the prediction API,
as an enterprise customer, you
want to control what goes in.
The post payload should not
contain any sensitive data.
If that is a use case
that you want to solve,
again, Apigee can be
your enforcement point.
There, we can make sure
that the request that
goes into this prediction
API are not sensitive data.
We can enforce things like data
loss prevention, regex checks,
the common things
that people want
to do to ensure that
this tensor data is not
going into the Cloud platform.
So in essence, what happens
here is enterprise customers
are now comfortable
that they have
a layer that's acting
as a gatekeeper,
so they can get started
with their initial project
on the cloud.
So once they do that, the second
architecture that we're seeing,
again, think of it
as a progression.
Now you've done your first,
second, third projects
on the cloud.
Now you want to move some
of your existing workloads.
You want to lift and
shift some of your VMs,
or you want to modernize
and containerized them
into something like GKE.
So if you're doing
something like that,
again, Apigee becomes a crucial
piece as an abstraction layer
that we're talking about today.
And the things that we do
can be slightly different.
For example, as you
move the workloads,
there are two or three problems
that we're seeing commonly.
One, the amount of
authentication schemes
that come into
picture increases.
Let's say, on-prem,
you may be doing two,
three, authentication models.
It could be a SAML-based
authentication.
It could be a web-service
security-based authentication.
It could be two or three others.
And now, once you
move to GCP, you
will end up with something
like a service account
with authentication, App Engine
firewalls, or the mutual SSL.
So managing that
becomes a tricky thing.
The second thing that happens
is you cannot move everything
at once.
Let's say you picked the
workload that you want to move.
There could be parts
of that workload,
there could be an appliance,
that you cannot move
immediately to the cloud.
So whatever you're
lifting and shifting--
could be a VM that
you're shifting,
or could be a modernized,
containerized GKE workload that
you're moving to Cloud--
that has to inevitably access
something or the other on-prem.
And that's the area where Apigee
can again solve and make sure
that your cloud backends and
accessing whatever backends
that you cannot move on day one
or move at all and give you one
consistent experience on how you
consume these applications from
a cloud standpoint.
And similarly, unifying
security, for example,
in this slide, we're talking
about the scenario where
your backend may have a
SAML-based authentication,
but you are consuming the
structure of GKE applications
using joud--
J-O-U-D-- validation.
So you want to consume
the on-prem the same way.
So you want to send a joud token
and access the on-prem systems.
But the on-prem knows only SAML.
So Apigee is the layer that is
acting as a mediation engine,
making sure that those
translations are happening
properly.
Similarly, the use case
that I talked about
is data translations--
SOAP to REST, XML to JSON.
You may want to consumer
a JSON, but your backend
is exposing an XML.
So what do you do?
You use Apigee as a mediation
layer or the API Gateway
to get the information
that you are looking for.
So that's the second step.
Once you do these
two successfully,
you have initial projects,
and you've proved success
with your cloud journey.
And then you are
comfortable moving
some of your existing workloads,
lift them and shift them
to the cloud.
And then, you come
to this final state
where you have a hybrid cloud.
You have a scenario where
you have workloads that
are across on-prem and cloud.
You could use solutions like
Google Cloud Interconnect
or VPC [INAUDIBLE] to
make sure that the data is
accessible to these two
from the backend standpoint.
But for external
consumption, they
do not want to know
the difference.
They should not care where
the backends are running.
If you have a backend that has
one workload on GKE and one
workload on-prem, on
Kubernetes, your clients
will not want to
know the difference.
They don't want
to send one token
to a GKE-based backend
and another token
to an on-prem based
Kubernetes backend.
They want to unify that
across the backends.
Let's say you also
want to integrate that
with your existing IDP, like an
LDAP or a cloud-based identity
provider that you're
leveraging internally.
So those are the things
that Apigee can solve.
And then there could be
higher level functions.
You may want to monetize
some of the APIs
that you're putting out there.
So Apigee can be the
layer where you are
applying the [INAUDIBLE] plans.
You are applying the
monetization plans.
You charged the developer.
So you pay the developers
for using the API.
And that should be
uniform across wherever
the workloads are coming from.
We talked about developer
portals, developer services.
You put up one single portal.
So you put all the APIs from
all these different backends.
Developers or your partners
are just looking at one portal.
All of the implementation detail
is kind of hidden from them.
So that's a third
use case, really,
where, once you get to
the true hybrid scenario,
you have Apigee acting
as your entry point
across all your
backends, making sure
that you have one consistent
unified experience on how
your APIs are being consumed
by internal developers,
by external developers,
and by your partners.
Those are the three patterns.
One, start with a Greenfield.
Pick up the first use case that
you want to use in the cloud.
Apigee can make
sure that whatever
you're doing in the
cloud in that project
is accessible to
your on-prem systems.
So you have that integrated.
And the second use case--
once you're comfortable with
one, two, three projects,
you move some of your
workloads to Cloud.
Apigee is making
sure that whatever
you are moving to Cloud, if
it has to access something
developer, you can do that.
And if it has to do mediations,
do data translations,
you do that on the Apigee layer.
So you build the
code the way you do.
You containerize it.
You lift and shift
the way you want to.
In the third use case,
you have a hybrid cloud.
You have customers
coming from outside.
You have other
teams using the API.
You give them one single
consistent experience
while you keep changing where
the workloads are running.
Those are the three patterns
that are very high level.
So what I'll do now is jump
from the slides to a demo.
But before I do that,
I wanted to do us
a quick context of what we'll be
demoing in the context of what
we just spoke about.
For the demo, this
is a set up slide.
I do have a VM that
has a hotel's API.
The demo, I'm taking
a use case where
it's a hospitality company.
They have information
about a bunch of hotels.
You look at the
hotel information.
ratings, reviews.
And then you select the hotel.
And you can do the booking.
So that's the backend
that we're talking about.
So traditionally,
think of the scenario
where they have built
all of that on their VMs.
And they want to move
some of those to the GKE
to manage Kubernetes, and
it's the easiest place
where you can containerize
and shift your workloads.
In this use case, they're not
moving everything at once.
They're picking the
hotel catalog information
and moving that to GKE and
rest of it will stay on VM.
And even that, as you are
going through the journey,
the scenario that
we're talking about
is think of this is a
customer who wants to do
or a kind of redeployment
or kind of reupgrade.
They don't want to move all the
clients to a GKE-based backend
once they build it.
They want to try that
with the [INAUDIBLE]
maybe internal applications.
And then once they
are comfortable they
know how the process works,
how the scaling works,
then they will move the
rest of the clients.
So they're using Apigee
as an abstraction layer.
They're deciding
what should go to GKE
and what should go to VMs.
And that's the demo
we'll be talking about.
And remember, the use case
really is just workload demo.
As for the workloads, like
payments, like reservations.
they'll continue being
on VMs until they're
comfortable moving those also.
That's the context for the demo.
So now, what I'll do is
I'll switch my screen
and show you the interfaces.
I'll be walking you through
two or three interfaces.
One interface is the Cloud
platform, the Cloud console,
which is where how my VMs or how
my Kubernetes-based backends.
And the second interface
that I'll walk you through
is the Apigee interface.
This is the place where you're
managing the APIs, where
you are doing the routing,
enforcing policies, and looking
at analytics, and generally
managing the APIs.
So these are the thing that
I'll be walking you through.
And of course, I do have my own
application, the APIs that I've
created, and the UI
that consumes the hotel
data that I was talking about.
What you have here
is a bunch of VMs
that are acting as the backend
for my hotel's base backed.
And I have a
spring-based app that
is serving information about
hotels catalog, reservations,
payments.
All of that is driven by the
spring application talking
to my SQL in the back.
Generally speaking,
in production,
you would probably have
three or four or five
of these VMs to give you the
resilience high availability.
And you probably
will [INAUDIBLE]
the capacity for your peak,
even though the peak is
happening maybe one or
two months in a bad year.
That's a common scenario anyway.
So here, I have this VM.
If I access this
[? /hotels ?] API,
you will see that I
get an array of hotels.
Each of the elements
in the array
is telling me information
about one single hotel--
the ratings, reviews, links
to where they're coming from.
That's my backend.
This is the shell
prompt for my VM.
So what I'm doing now is taking
this particular API I just
showed you-- the
hotel's catalogue--
and moving that to
a GKE-based backend.
What I've done is taken an
existing spring application,
and then taken a piece
of that, and taken
that piece of spring code.
And I'm using cloud
SQL in the backend.
Because once I containerize,
I can leverage these factors
that I can attach
to my application.
And the cloud SQL can probably
scale my data much better
than what I could do on my own
on my VM-based infrastructure.
So now, if I do the
[INAUDIBLE] services,
you will see that I have
two services that I've
deployed on Kubernetes.
One of them is the hotel's
API, which is just the catalogs
API and nothing else.
The rest-- the payments, the
reservations-- all of that
is staying back with the
VM-based infrastructure
that I was just showing you.
And then I do have
the hotel's UI
that is serving as
the UI for this demo.
So before I show the
UI, I just wanted
to quickly show you the hotels.
There are two things that you
may notice as a difference.
One is, as I am, let's say,
modernizing or containerizing
my application, I have added
a version number to my app,
to my API.
So my API URLs slightly
look different.
And the second thing
that you may notice
is the resource structure
itself is slightly different.
For example, in
my other backend,
I have the hotels
as a simply JSON.
But as I built a
second version, I
have an element called portals.
And inside that is an array
that shows the hotel's data.
These changes are expected.
You may notice that as good
you're developing applications,
as you are upgrading your
API versions, some of these
are natural.
But the most important thing
is you do not want your clients
to see the difference.
That's the part that Apigee's
solving for you, which
I'm going to show you in a bit.
But before that, this is my UI.
It's a simple UI, where from
a contradiction standpoint,
I will give my API
key that I want
to use, and send a request,
and it will give me information
about all the hotels.
It's a very simple UI.
This information could be coming
from one, or two, or three
backends.
For example, when
I click on book,
this could be going to
the reservations API.
That is being served
by the springboard app.
Whereas this information, the
catalogue information itself,
is coming from a
GKE-based packet.
So now, I talked
about a scenario
where the client wants to do
a [INAUDIBLE] based upgrade.
They do not want to move
all the clients at once.
So they're using
Apigee to decide
which ones they want to move.
For example, if I use
this particular API key,
Apigee will know that
this is an app that
has to go to a GKE-based packet
and will route the request
accordingly.
Whereas, if I use
another API key,
there is an application
attribute for this key.
And when Apigee
looks at this, it
knows that this has to go to
a VM-based spring backend.
When I send a request, it
goes to the VM-based backend.
But as a developer, you
won't see the difference.
We talked about the
fact that the APIs
could be slightly different.
All of that is hidden.
You'll want this UI
code to access these two
APIs separately and render
them in different ways.
So those are the kinds of
things that Apigee is doing
for you behind the scenes.
So what I'll do now is
switch to the Apigee UI
to show you what's
happening behind the scenes,
as I'm doing what I
was doing in the UI.
So what I have here
is the trace window.
So for example, when I was
sending those two requests,
this is my first request.
And this is my second request.
So the second request, what
you're seeing specifically
on the screen is what we
call as a trace window.
This is your debugging tool.
This is the place you come to
when you want to introspect
what's happening with the API.
But in the context
of the UI, the UI
sent a request with slash
we want slash hotels
and with the API key.
And the first thing
we're doing is
we're making sure that
the API key is valid
and this API key can access
this hotel's resource.
And it's not an invalid key.
So now, in addition to doing
that, what we are also doing
is we're picking up a lot of
these variables that could be
application-specific variables.
And one of those
variables is telling me
that this particular application
has a configuration that
says that the request should
go to the VM-based backend.
And that is an attribute
called API key dot backend.
And once I look
at that attribute,
I'm doing a routing
based on that.
So there's a route
condition that matched.
And now' I know that I have to
send it to a VM-based backed.
And what you will notice is we
are sending it to slash hotels,
even though the request came
to slash we want slash hotels.
And this is what the
backend responded back with.
And as you have seen before,
this is a simple array.
It doesn't have the
hotel's element.
And without that,
the UI will fail.
So you'll see that there is
a policy here on the response
pipeline where we're
taking the response that
was given to us by the
backend and massaging that
into something that
the UI will understand.
In this case, it's a simple
JavaScript per JavaScript
translation.
But we have seen more things are
done on Apigee, like a SOAP XML
to [INAUDIBLE] translation, or
even talking to two or three
backends behind the scenes
and aggregating them
into one single unified API.
So that's the trace window.
But as an API
management platform,
you do get a lot
of other things.
For example, you can
look at all the APIs
that came to your system.
And then you can measure
what's happening.
You can see which
developer applications.
Let's say you see a
sudden spike on your API
at this point in time.
You can ask Apigee
to tell you what's
happening at that point in time,
which developer application is
sending traffic.
Is it a valid one?
Is it invalid one?
Should you enforce more quotas?
Those are the
information that you
want to know as an API owner.
And for example,
if are suspecting
that there could be a specific
client IP address that
is sending a
[INAUDIBLE] request,
you can look at the analytics.
It will tell you where the
requests are coming from.
And if you see that there is
an invalid IP address that
is sending a bunch of requests,
you can block them right there.
So those other things that
you do from an API management
standpoint.
One-- use the policies.
I was showing you
the trace, but these
are the full set of
policies that you can
use from a platform standpoint.
For example, you can add a spike
in this policy and say that,
any request going to
my VM-based backed,
I know that it cannot scale as
well as my GKE-based backend.
So let's take that and
make sure that it does not
get more than 100
requests per second.
We talked about things
like DLP, regex checks--
all these are available for
you from a security standpoint.
And if you want to do
things like mediation,
translating XML to JSON,
XML to XML, JSON to JSON,
all those translations
or mediations
are something that you can do.
And also, you can
go to the extent of,
let's say, plugging
in your own code.
You can write your own
Java code or [INAUDIBLE]
code or JavaScript
code to tell what
should be done when request
comes from the client
or when the response is
going back to the client.
That's a quick demo
of the product.
Again, there's a lot
more to the product.
Once you make your APIs
operationally ready,
you can put the documentation.
You can put a developer portal
where your developers come to.
They need not see any of this
or any of the infrastructure
underneath.
They look at a single website,
which is your developer portal,
and they use that
to access the APIs.
So all of that information
is available for you online.
You can try with the product.
You can look at
additional scenarios
on where API management
can become useful
in the context of a full
[INAUDIBLE] API management.
But today, I want to talk in
the context of how this API
management platform can
allow you to move workloads
across on-prem cloud by
acting as an abstraction layer
to give you the flexibility
to move things around.
So that's the quick demo on
how API management platform is
solving one specific use
case and that use case is
moving workloads from
cloud to on-prem.
And in the process, you may
want to modernize and move them,
or you may just
want to [INAUDIBLE]
an existing VM to GCE.
But the abstraction layer
is important for enterprises
to get that flexibility, to
get that assurance that things
won't break, things won't
get impacted for people
who are consuming them.
So where can you go from here?
We'll be doing a
lot more webinars
around this topic
and other topics
on how API management is
relevant in the context
of Cloud.
But more importantly, you can
play with the product hands-on.
We have a lot of hands-on labs.
You see that we do what
we call as API jams.
This is a place where you can
touch and feel the product.
You can play with the product.
You can build some
of the policies
that we're showing you.
You can do them virtually.
And we do it on these
API jams on site.
So you can come to one of them
and learn about the product.
And if you want to
get a free trial
or get access to the product
and try some of this yourself,
you can do that as well.
So that's the quick demo.
So what I'll do now
is take a quick break.
Stay tuned for the live Q&A.
I'll take a quick break.
In less than a minute, I'll
come back, look at the questions
that we have on the Q&A
panel, take the common ones,
and answer them for you here.
Awesome.
Great questions, everybody.
And these are the
common questions
that we captured, really
interesting questions.
The first question
is, can I use Apigee
even if I'm not using
Kubernetes or GKE?
Yeah, absolutely.
Like I was showing in
that architect slide,
people sometimes
want to modernize
and sometimes they want to
modernize in other ways.
Kubernetes or not,
GKE or not, there's
a need for API management.
And there's a need
to move workloads
around that is abstracted
from whoever is using it
or abstracted from the client.
So absolutely.
You can Apigee, even if you're
not using Kubernetes or GKE.
So the second question here
is, I do not have mobile apps.
Is Apigee still relevant?
Yeah, sure, absolutely.
This is a common
question for us.
So when we talk about apps--
and this happened
more so in the past,
because now, when
we say apps, people
understand that even the backend
code, the backend systems
of records are also apps.
But when we talk
about app, we're
just not talking
about mobile apps.
It could be an
intel integration.
It could be another business
unit within your enterprise
that want to consume your APIs.
Even though we call that an app
from a construct consumability
standpoint, yeah, absolutely,
they're not always mobile apps.
You can use Apigee even if
they're not mobile apps.
The third question we have is,
do I have to rewrite my code--
I think it's rewrite--
to use Apigee's API
management features?
No.
So this is one
advantage of having
Apigee as an abstraction layer.
Once you put Apigee out there--
at a very high level, we
talked about API services.
That really is a proxy to
your backend implementation.
So even if you have a
legacy backend that has,
let's say, a poor
performance, you
don't have to
completely rewrite that.
You can if you want to.
But with Apigee,
what you're doing is
you're putting a facade.
You're putting a proxy.
And there, you are doing
things like mediation.
So you don't have to
rewrite your backend
to be able to do that.
And then we have
another question.
Can Apigee manage APIs
of our SaaS-based?
I think this is a
common question.
Like I say, backends, SaaS-based
backends, yeah, absolutely.
You can do that.
You can proxy your
SaaS applications
and have Apigee proxy them.
And there, you may
want to do things
like integrate with your
existing identity provider,
make it look more seamless,
translate the data formats.
Or sometimes you're
seeing customers
who take a SaaS-based
backend and on-prem-based
and combine them and
create an API match-up.
And that could be
a use case that you
want to solve [INAUDIBLE]
development use cases
for Apigee.
The other question, I think
it's very specific to our Google
Cloud managed offering.
Can I leverage Google
Cloud Interconnect,
even if I use Apigee
manged offering?
Yeah, totally.
That's something that we're
working through in partnership
with the rest of the teams
within the Google Cloud.
You should be able to leverage
the Google Cloud Interconnect.
The beauty of that is you will
have one seamless connectivity
between your Apigee managed
offering, your cloud project,
and your on-prem project.
So the performance is awesome.
I've seen customers
who testify to that.
Absolutely.
Awesome benefits of doing that.
I think the other
question we have
is, can I have
separate developer
portals for internal developers
versus external partners.
Yeah, totally.
You can have them.
And the other follow-up question
is, can I have different APIs?
Yes.
We're seeing customers do that.
You may find internal
developers have
a portal that has all the APIs.
Could be your legacy
backends or other backends.
And for the external
developers, you
may want to expose only
those that you control,
that you know are you
comfortable sharing.
And you can do that in
a [? phase ?] manner.
So absolutely, you can do that.
I think those are pretty
much the questions I have.
And we'll continue
following up on the channel.
We'll answer the questions
on the channel live.
And after that, if you
have any other questions,
you can reach out to us
on this email address,
which is
apigee-up-close@google.com.
We'll be following that email
and answer the questions.
Based on the feedback,
we'll probably
do a follow-up
webinar or webinars
to keep the momentum going.
Awesome.
With that, thank you, guys.
Have a good day.
And I'll see you again
at the other webinars.